a lot of what we are as humans comes  from when you were younger as a  two-year-old you know how you sometimes  pretend to cry because crying allowed  your mom to go like okay baby  something's wrong tap you on the back or  remove whatever was annoying you just  give you attention so there is a utility  to that most of our problems with  happiness are because some of us decided  not to grow Beyond sex oh okay okay yeah  so while you start to tell yourself  there's no utility to that I can  actually get up myself and get the  Nutella jar that I wanted I don't have  to wait for mommy anymore why am I  crying or I can actually take charge of  my life so if life is a little  challenging I can cry for mommy but  mommy is not gonna show up if my boss is  annoying